please have your stuffed animals dolls
and diapers ready
right here this
man changing the doo-doo diaper we
brought together seven
teen dads i am a teen dad i'm a teen dad
i am 18 dad i am a teen dad i'm a teen
dad
i am a teen dad i'm a teen dad
i'm a teen dad one is a liar
if the group discovers who the liar is
they'll win a cash prize if the liar
survives they win a cash prize
this is odd man out
so my plan of attack is to pretty much
try to put pressure on the team dads ask
them a lot of questions
see if they know some things about
babies or how to change babies do you
remember
how much formula cost or how much the
diapers cost
i'm feeling confident i'm pretty sure
that i'm going to win this
[Music]
alrighty who does uh who does your
guys's baby mainly live with is it the
mother father you guys live together
me and my girlfriend actually do live
together but we are not married yet
my son mainly stays at um her house they
stay over on like the weekend
because she's still in a high school me
and my girlfriend we still we i mean
we just started living together recently
so today we stay
all together i'm not with my baby mom
but i try to get my son at least every
week
me and my wife we're married together
our kids we all live together
me and my girlfriend and our baby all
live together so what do your kids like
to watch
baby einstein i don't know if you guys
heard of it yeah she loves that she eats
it up
my baby she loves watching pokemon yeah
she watches it all the time
yeah my son he watches coco melon pj
masks and i'll be putting him on the
anime like naruto
oh nice what is you guys is the easiest
way to calm down your child when he or
she is lying fit
food definitely food if i feed him he'll
stop grinding immediately my son just
likes being held and he likes just
having like his back rubbed
oh my son he takes a binky so he's
pretty good about the binky i usually
get like toys and try to entertain him
calm
down first and then we start to talk
because he's a little older now
yeah my baby definitely like i just pick
her up she loves me like i'm her
favorite
i pick her up i just say her name and
then she's perfectly fine
i feel pretty confident that they're not
going to think it was me i was being a
little assertive but i was not trying to
push it overboard i think i'm gonna go
for nick
i'm going to be voting out ethan he just
seems the least
dad-like to me when the question was
asked about how do you calm down your
baby
darren said that as soon as he picks his
baby up they stopped crying and that's
not really realistic
between nick or sean i would have to go
with
nick i'm most suspicious of darren cause
healy
i feel like he said the least and i
noticed that because at the end i had
for a guy he was in the zoom call
for this round i'm going to be voting
off thomas i felt like he stuttered
when he gave his answers i'm about to do
a
coin flip in my head between ethan and
darren let's flip
this clicker right now
all right the votes are in for round one
and we have a three-way tie
between ethan darren and nick
wow a three-way time that means we're
going into a tiebreaker
each person will get 20 seconds to state
your case
let's start with ethan so i am 17 years
old
my girlfriend and i got pregnant when
we're 16.
my baby was born born in july and she is
now seven months
me and my girlfriend met in eighth grade
that's when we first got together she
got pregnant when she was 15 had the
baby at 16. i love being a teen dad
i love everything about it the maturity
everything i realized some of the things
i said probably seemed weird like i said
i was married and i showed my left hand
i don't have a ring uh i have eczema
my daughter is about to turn two she was
born in may my son was one in december
he just turned a month old
yeah i i stuttered a little bit here and
there uh my brain
really went blank hopefully it was
enough i still think
it's darren i'm going to be voting off
ethan sorry nick
i don't know man the other the other two
seem pretty confident
i think nick is safe but darren i'm
still
i still think darren is sucks the person
eliminated in round one
is darren i knew it
i felt like it was going to be me i
don't know why
maybe the way i was talking i don't know
all right this is a diaper change round
you will each be changing a diaper on an
inanimate
object and show everyone how well you
can change a diaper
please have your stuffed animals dolls
and diapers ready
we're gonna start with
right nick breaking the baby's leg with
that one this
man changing the doodoo diaper you're
pretty rough with it i know it's not a
real baby but
jesus
look if you're professional depending
how much how messy it is
it should really only take two wipes
all over thomas did pretty good
that is not how you roll up a diaper
bruh ain't he through the white mouth so
why would you throw the white outside
the diaper
[Music]
just killed this baby no i think the
baby's dead from that one
this is harder than actual changing my
son
so usually what i do first i take a
couple wipings
i open it up i hold her legs
okay folding the legs okay get under it
very back
you gotta make it tight so i want to put
it and
diaper jeans i like to do that too when
i was changing my size diaper i always
used to do that make it really tight
side down so if she ever has a blow out
it's covered
alright now strap it pull this down keep
that under here have a girl so you
always wipe down or have to so there's
the wipes typically if she poops i'll
use more
uh put them inside of there i was about
to say why are they not putting the
wipes in the diaper but then he did it
the sloth is pretty big for this but
you can see it is done to be honest i
think i did good i took a little longer
than most
but it was very thorough i think i'm
gonna go with tushan
i think isaiah did really well with the
diaper change and sean
he sucks this round i'm going to be
voting for nick because of the tie break
round last round and because of his poor
diaper changing skills
i have a little suspicious still on nick
i'm going to vote for sean off this
round
kind of hard to tell you know the mole's
really good i am just going to say
taijan because you dropped the baby
we counted all the votes and the person
eliminated this round
is taishan
wow damn i really thought they were
gonna vote me out this round
i understand why i was eliminated it's
probably because i dropped pikachu but
that's just because i didn't have enough
space right here
i think a lot of people think of teen
dads like kind of pathetic like they're
not going to be there for their children
they're not going to stay they don't
care they're there for the girl until
the girl leaves it could be true
for some fathers but i genuinely think
in the grand scheme of things
all of us if none of us are them all are
genuinely here for our children
i feel like life just changes like a
hundred percent when you have a kid like
your perspective of life
everything you thought that you knew
just goes out the window
oh yeah having a child really does
mature you
quick like really quick oh yeah what was
your guys's parents reactions to it
oh my gosh and then your girlfriend's
parents as well because those are when
the good reactions started yo
my girlfriend's mom kicked her out and
she ended up coming to live with me
and then like a year later we ended up
getting kicked out
so now we're living with her dad that
she hasn't talked to for six years bro
my mom's side loved it supportive
they're very feminist they love to hear
that i was having a baby girl they're so
happy
comes to my dad's side my brother
punched me in the gut he was not too
happy about it and then over on the
mother's side
i had to she was about to take me to
court but uh everything's worked out now
my dad was like the most supportive
person in my life at that time
my mom she was just very like
disappointed like i'm her youngest
she thought like that i was like i
failed her and then my dad eventually
talked to her
and she kind of like warmed up to the
idea of it my wife's family they
they actually were all very angry and it
was upsetting because they all pushed
abortion immediately oh you're 16 you
got to go get an abortion i remember
when i was in middle school because she
had got pregnant when
we were still in middle school and one
of the teachers had told us like
you should get an abortion i think that
was one of the worst parts about that
was just
constantly being told to get an abortion
my girlfriend's mom said this is your
option
get an abortion you stay at home or have
the kid you're getting kicked out
i never had to go through that i'm
pro-life personally so thank you all for
not making that choice my views have
changed because
i had a baby so now that i have this
attachment i just i can't see anybody
doing that it's
such a horrible thing with this round i
feel like it was
hard to book someone out because i feel
like everyone had a good convincing
story
this round i'm going to be voting on
nick just because of his prior rounds
i'm still suspicious of nick and to be
honest i'm actually shifting to thomas
now
i really don't feel like anyone it is
is the mall but i'm sorry sean
i'm gonna have to go with thomas just
because this man was pretty quiet for a
lot of it
i'm going to vote sean off this round
and we have to vote
i guess because i have to vote this is
what i'm voting for the votes are in and
we have a tie
between sean and thomas each one of you
will get
20 seconds to state your case and we're
gonna start with thomas
my son i had him for
i had him for four years already and
damn when i got choked up so many things
it's such a beautiful thing to have a
child
and have them every day with me and be
able to
just keep them around and have fun with
him
i think the biggest thing about being a
father is just loving your child
unconditionally
and even with your your wife or your
girlfriend my example
you just learn to like how to parent and
be a couple as well
you learn how like there's differences
you're going to have your arguments with
them but you have your parental roles as
well and you don't let that get in the
way of parenting
i'm starting to feel i don't know it
kind of swayed me a little bit someone
on shawn's side i think my vote went to
thomas sean did a really good
on speaking i'm voting i i know i said
thomas but sean
never really said my baby he always says
yours he doesn't have one
the person eliminated this round is
sean i'm kind of mad a little bit upset
about being eliminated
i think that we all genuinely trusted
each other but we just had to get
through the round
give me a thumbs up if you want to
continue the game if not
give me a thumbs down and you want to
end the game now let's see who puts her
thumb down first
show me your thumbs in three two
one all right we're half and half
i'm getting thomas out we will vote one
more time
in three two one
okay nick has changed his vote we're
continuing the game and going to round
four
all right thomas yeah so you haven't
brought up your girlfriend that much
when did you guys end up splitting up we
never split up we all stayed together
we we live together now actually i
noticed that you don't have
really any toys of the baby do you have
any laying around like
yeah i do i mean for christmas he got a
lot of toy story i mean
do you guys want me to show you yeah
yeah well i have a buzz lightyear i mean
he got this
before christmas actually how old is
your
child he's four years old how was
y'all's uh experience as far as like
when your
partner was in in labor she went into
labor
early they actually didn't let me in the
room because they're like it's an
emergency so they had me wait in like
some
like room and i was just there just
waiting like nervous
with my experiences my baby uh it was a
c-section
i wasn't there it was during the whole
coven thing uh i couldn't be there they
wouldn't let letting me in
the baby was born i did get pictures
right as she was born
the best pictures i've ever had in my
life i love them my baby was born
naturally
she actually came three weeks before her
due date they actually had to induce my
girlfriend 20 minutes bro i swear i
thought it was going to take forever
but it was so fast the first time i was
my daughter when she finally started
pushing she actually pushed for
about two minutes and it was done quick
with my son though it was completely
different the anesthesiologist
was doing an epidural for someone else
so my wife actually almost ended up
getting a natural birth
like if i had to choose anyone it'll
probably be like the way he explained
his stuff
was a little shaky i was bony making the
very first round
but now thomas is seeming more
suspicious i'm going to vote thomas out
this round
i'm gonna i'm gonna have to say thomas
no i don't know
i don't know i don't want to anymore the
votes are in for round four and the
person
eliminated this round is
thomas i'm sorry thomas
i did it i had i figured they were gonna
do that
okay give me a thumbs up if you want to
continue the game
if not give me a thumbs down if you
think you caught them all and want to
end the game now
i mean i have my suspicion on nick but
you know he pulled through at the end so
let's see i'm really scared it's going
to be nick but you know i gave my all if
we don't win
we don't win i hope we're right about
this it could run to the same page here
show me your thumbs in three two
one okay everyone has voted thumbs down
we will end the game now
all right if the background turns green
you all win
if it's red the mole is still in the
game and you all lost
in three two one
all right nick nick i'm not gonna lie
i'm so suspicious of this
i was really suspicious of you too but
like after the first one i was like no
there's no way
all right the game is over and the teen
dads have won
that means that the winners will be
getting a cash prize now
will the fake teen dad please raise your
hand in three
two one
what i knew it i
knew it well my brother's actually he
was a team dad
so i kind of just like tried portraying
his experiences as my own
his kids go live with us but she's seven
now and he also told me how to change a
diaper so
say hi to all the babies
this is my baby girl this is my son
he just turned two her name is ella
rayne
ella after a rainbow six siege character
video game
nice love siege to have
this my son and i'm telling you he likes
buzz lightyear i'm telling you i was a
lion
[Music]